we're in a quick unquote new topic it's
new because we weren't doing fractions
last lesson but it's not new because of
course you are familiar with fractions
we've met these before so what we're
going to do is we're going to just
quickly remember some old cover some old
ground that we do know and then we're
gonna get straight into it
can anyone tell me the word fraction it
starts off with um this kind of sort of
sub word if you like that we use in
another word like if you break your arm
we would say you've got a a fracture
very good and that idea there that
you've got something which has been
broken into pieces that's all we mean by
a fraction instead of whole things it's
like no we're just talking about the
parts of it bravi doing getting that for
us thank you okay so I just want to
remind you of the fact that we generally
speaking have three different forms of
fractions and we also want to be able to
convert between them and that's what
we're just going to review for today so
for starters can someone just give me an
example of a fraction any fraction that
you like said again three by five okay
so I'm gonna write this down now I think
what you mean is three over five right
now I will say often you will hear that
said thank you very often you will hear
it said exactly the way Jessica tiered
some people say three by five right but
of course a little bit like this like if
you saw this you know there's an
operation that's hiding in there we
would say what's the missing operation
its x right now we kind of agree yeah
there's a x in there but when you hear
the words three by five there's a word
also hiding just like there's an
operation hiding what's the word that
Jessica is hiding in here three by five
divides very good three divided by five
but I'm just gonna put a caution on this
because I used to say this but then I
noticed some other people when they said
the same phrase three by five they will
hiding a different word they weren't
hiding divided they were actually hiding
this word yeah three times or 3
multiplied by five so I'm going to as
much as I can catch me if I'm mistaken
we do it I'm not gonna call this three
by five because it's a bit ambiguous if
I write it down you know what it is but
because we've got an E
right here that is smaller than the
denominator what would we call this
what kind of fracture would you call
that just yeah a proper fraction is the
word we would the name we would usually
give to this it's a proper fraction now
if you've got a proper fraction what's
the opposite of a proper fraction this
improper very good can someone give me
an example of an improper fraction
addition 9 over 1 sure why not
okay so this is improper because rather
than the numerator being smaller than
the doughnut it's the other way around
isn't it so we'll call this guy an
improper fraction and then lastly
there's one on the form that's kind of
like the improper fraction but different
every time mixed so I've got mixed and
then I add another word on to it a mixed
we tend to call the mixed numerals that
it's still the same idea the idea that
it's mixed a mixed numeral between it's
like a fraction bit and there's also a
yeah as a whole number part isn't there
can someone give me an example of a
mixed numeral jacker ok 3 and 5/7 right
so it's a bit weird because you know
again there's an operation hiding in
here that we don't say but we kind of
assume that you know what it is it's not
x like here what's the hiding operation
it's just plus which is it's a bit funny
isn't it it's a bit like wait can you
make up your mind what's the theme of
you're hiding the context kind of tells
you what is missing there's a plus
hiding in there in fact I might even
encourage all of you to write down next
to that that's 3 plus 5 over 7 that's
where it's really appreciated okay so
real quick there are two kinds of
conversions that we're going to be
interested in recovery
Georgia suggests one
okay so that's one of them so you could
turn one of these into the other right
both of these are bigger than one so you
could convert this for example this mix
numeral we could turn it into an
improper fraction so let's think about
this right mix numeral now you've seen
before Marik we know you can get the
answer but that's not the part that's
most interesting to us so let's let's
think about it
to go from a mixed Nero hold up hold
your thought I know you've got it I know
you've got it I want to also have it
right together mix T rule to an improper
fraction let's actually do this in make
sure the right answer but on one pack
why he does he did seven times three why
did he do seven times three
hmm because I know that you can do it
but I want to know why you're doing it
Leo what are you thinking ah very good
that's so good I want to repeat that
word for word because this is three
wholes right
three holes there it's like having seven
over seven three times so I'd love us to
write that down aptly that's seven over
seven three times and that's why Marik
did the multiplication right so that
there is the three out the front and
then of course we agreed that the thing
that's missing the operation that's
missing in there is plus five over seven
and at this point you can tell me what
is seven times three it's 21
very good that's how many sevenths we
have over here and then we've got five
more of them over here like so and
that's why we can say in total how many
sevens are they in this mixture yeah
very good twenty-six over seven so
that's how they would go from a Nix
niets Murrell to an improper fraction we
would reverse that if we wanted to go
the other way around there's one other
thing that I just want to remind you is
the case which is about these guys do
you remember what these are equivalent
fractions what does it mean when two
fractions are equivalent Ernie
yeah okay very good - before and forever
eight why don't we write that as an
example - over four is equal to they're
the same size even though I'm writing a
different American okay 0.5 would be the
same again though I do notice the 0.5 is
a is a different way of writing it's a
lot of fraction actually it's a decimal
yeah even though the size is the same
did did you have a question or I thought
just stretching yeah okay ah yeah you've
taken the numerator and multiply by two
and then you took the denominator and
you also multiplied that by two could
someone give me maybe one more
equivalent fraction into both of these
Jessica 8 over 16 we've doubled again or
you could have gone straight over by
multiplying by 4 top and bottom is
really important okay no okay so all of
these fractions are equivalent but none
of them is the simplest is it so 1 over
2 would be the simplest way to write any
of these but sometimes why might we've
sometimes want to write a fraction even
though it's not in its simplest form
Croton very good if you have two
fractions together and you're adding
them and they're not the same
denominator we might make it not the
simplest form so that you can talk to
each other
well that's question merrick that's okay
that's right now this is what we're just
going to review today you know how to do
this stuff okay
now there is an exercise in the textbook
but frankly it's a little bit boring so
I don't want to give it to you so
instead actually I should ask would
anyone like to just do the textbook the
exercise because you can if you want
such a miracle a dancer okay he's only
gonna do being that I got this
resounding nerve I'm going to give you
two challenges and you've seen me give
you these before this is supposed to be
my iPad in my bag boys so these are not
going to be quick questions
could you make a little subheading which
is thank you cease to open problems to
open prob
okay now you may as soon as you see this
you might recognize it yes Bashar oh
very good
EQ UI V that's a bad a le MT is that
okay I did spell it right it was just
Missy
that's right it's not awakened okay so
here are my two open problems in each
case you can use the digits 0 to 9 at
most once you don't have to use all of
them as you'll see in a second but you
can you can't like use 3 more than once
or you can't use 5 more than one
something like that ok so here are the
two challenges I'd like you to use these
digits to fill in this statement here so
I've got a fraction over here which is
two digits on the top and two digits on
the bottom and I want an equivalent
fraction that is just one digit on the
top and one digit on the bottom so
that's my first open problem it's open
because there are many solutions to this
I have a handful here but I'm keen to
I'm not gonna tell you how many because
last time I told you how many you guys
completely destroyed me so that's the
first one and then the second one starts
off the same way so you got another
two-digit on two digit fraction but what
I'd like it to be equal to is a mixed
numeral like so okay yes
ah so this is a two digit number so it's
not operations so for example you could
put 1 & 2 here and make 12 does that
make sense yeah ok so here are the two
open problems I'm gonna let you you can
choose which one you want to start with
though I did put this one first on
purpose see how many solutions you can
come up with no calculators for this one
I really want you to think and use your
brain because it just becomes boring if
you've got a calculator there okay so
good luck if you have some solutions let
us know and we'll see if you can beat
the number of solutions that I came up
with so good luck